في زياره مثيره للجدل وسط التوتر الحاصل
بين الغرب والصين وروسيا مستشار والمانيا
في بكين استقبال الرسميون من الرئيس
الصيني سرعان ما انتقل بعده الرجلان الى
طاوله الاجتماع كان عليهما الحديث اولا عن
الخلافات بين البلدين ثم الانتقال لدور
الموحد لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه بكل
تداعياتها في الوقت الحاضر الوضع الدولي
معقد مقابل للتغيير الصين والمانيا
باعتبارهما قوتين مؤثرتين يجب ان تعمل معا
في اوقات التغيير والفوضى لتقديم المزيد
من الاسهامات للسلام والتنميه في العالم
ورغم انتقاداتي زياره شمس للصين خصوصا من
امريكا وبريطانيا الا ان برلين اعلنت ان
زياره تهدف لاستغلال نفوذ بكين على موسكو
لوقف الحرب في اوكرانيا شباب خزلان لقد
قلت للرئيس الصيني انه من المهم ان تستخدم
الصين نفودها على روسيا الامر يتعلق
بضروره احترام مبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده
التي نلتزم بها جميعا وبمبادئ مثل السياده
ووحده الاراضي التي تعتبر مهمه ايضا
بالنسبه للصين
زياره الى بكين كانت قد وضعت زعيمه اكبر
قوه اقتصاديه في اوروبا امام عاصفه من
الانتقادات حيث اعتبرت خطوه فرديه تجاه
الصين جاءت بعدها رفضه اقتراح الرئيس
الفرنسي ماكرون بالسفر معا الى الصين
والذي اراد بها الاخير ارساله عن وحده
الاتحاد
الاوروبيترز كما واجه المستشار الالماني
اتهامات بانه يخلق مع الصين في المجال
التجاري نفس التبعيه التي تعاني منها
المانيا اليوم في مجال الطاقه مع روسيا
فضلا عن ان السلطات الالمانيه سمحت لشركه
صينيه مملوكه للدوله بالاستحواذ على حصه
في محطه ميناء همبرج وفي ختام زياره اعلى
من الرئيس الصينيو انه يجب اجراه حوار
سريع ومباشر لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه مرحبا
بدوري المانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي في حل
الازمه في انتقادهم ضمينيا للدوري
الامريكي والبريطاني من ما يحدث